alexandra korosteleva perdió a su hijo
de cinco meses kolia y a su marido milla
cuando un proyectil de un cañón ruso
cayó junto a ellos hacía poco que habían
regresado a su casa en jarquín están en
la misma tumba el marido de oleksandra
murió en el acto pero tardaron unas
cuatro horas en encontrar el cuerpo de
su hijo una onda expansiva lo hizo volar
hacia un edificio vecino éste derechosas
ya se fue con ya está muerto dijeron que
habían encontrado a mi hijo en el ático
de una tienda voló 10 metros en el aire
julia es sólo uno de los más de 200
niños que han muerto desde el comienzo
de la guerra el presidente del país
vladimir selenski centró su discurso
nocturno en los hijos muertos y heridos
con motivo del día internacional del
niño leyó los nombres de 10 niños
fallecidos
molina de 2 años de evolución que añade
14 años de buscar este pan de tres años
de un pueblo cercano a kiev sus pies con
sólo un hombre diez niños de esta lista
no son sólo números cada línea es un
mundo propio que fue destruido por el
ejército ruso
en vivo en el oeste de ucrania autobuses
escolares vacíos se alinearon en la
plaza central de la ciudad para
recordarlos en los asientos del autobús
los nombres de los fallecidos
es imposible comprender el dolor de los
padres que han perdido a sus hijos
nuestros niveles y por eso hacemos sonar
la campana para que el mundo vea lo que
está pasando y detenga cualquier
cooperación con rusia y justo ahora su
suicidio unicef dice que al menos dos
niños han sido asesinados cada día desde
el comienzo de la guerra